I'm going to try to demonstrate
something called regulation which is
where you provide a pressure onto ice
and that turns it into water but after
that pressure is removed it freezes
again so in order to demonstrate this
I've taken apart the high E string from
my guitar I chose the e string because
it's stinner than a g string and that's
important and I've waited it with these
two bottles of water when I apply the
string across the ice we should see the
wire start to cut through the ice and
perform the regulation of the ice well
we'll see if it works because we are
outside in Sydney and it's warmer than
zero degrees obviously
alright it's past 3:00 again but the
experiment has been a success I passed
this wire through this giant block of
ice and it's still a solid block you can
actually see the point where the wire
went through here so we pretty clearly
demonstrated read relation the idea that
you can compress the ice turn it into
water and then when that pressure is
gone it solidifies again as ice pretty
cool stuff